ми бачимо знов і знов що на жаль для
влади для Зеленського для його офісу
ціль дискредитації політичних опонентів
лишається такою ж актуальною як і до
повномасштабного вторгнення і На жаль
сьогодні ми є свідком ще однієї такої
атаки ми дуже часто навіть не реагуємо
щоб не піднімати негативних хвиль щоб не
роз'єднувати суспільство
розуміємо наскільки важливо сьогодні
загальне
спільне єдине бажання Перемоги і
відставляння будь-яких політичних
непорозумінь але ми знов і знов це
бачимо і це безглуздя в тому нема
жодного якогось пояснення це враження
таке як самоціль для когось хтось хоче
не захистити державу а бути черговим
таким героєм серіалу де тільки він тому
бачимо атаки і на залужного